many people have been joking around
yesterday and today about how all we
need now is a two-state solution and
that that will fix everything if we just
had a Palestinian State and the Israelis
and Palestinians living side by side in
peace and many people do of course still
assume and we are still hearing this
rhetoric that if only the Palestinians
had a state then everything would be
okay me meanwhile if we actually looked
at what the Palestinians themselves are
saying and have said with terrifying
consistency for decades now we would
know that no two-state solution will
solve anything but will only create a
new Jihad base for renewed attacks
against Israel this is a religious
War this is a religious War it is not a
political war or if you prefer
it is a political war fought for
religious reasons because the religious
system that is at War and started the
war and is the cause of the war
envisions a political system in which
the whole world is
subsumed under the hegemony of the
people who hold to this
religion Hamas made this abundantly
clear from the very beginning from its
Inception in the Hamas Charter from the
late 80s it says very clearly Israel
will rise and will continue until Islam
obliterates
it it didn't say Israel will rise and
continue until we uh work out a
two-state solution or Israel will rise
and continue until the proper
combination of concessions and
negotiations creates for a pathway to
peace there is no peace envisioned
except except through the obliteration
of Israel and the obliteration of Israel
comes from very basic and core Islamic
principles there is no state of Israel
even if it were the size of a Suburban
front yard that would be allowed to
exist in this framework in hamas's view
the state of Israel is an affront to
Islam it is not just an affront to the
Palestinians or stolen land or any of
the rhetoric that you hear all the time
the state of Israel is an insult to
Islam and as such it must be obliterated
why is the state of Israel an insult to
Islam well if you open your qurans to
chapter 2:
191 then you will see that it says drive
them out from where they drove you
out drive them out from where they drove
you out now that might seem that's very
very small phrase very easy to pass pass
by without realizing its implications
and yet its implications are absolutely
gigantic and cannot be understated drive
them out from where they drove you out
is predicated on the assumption that any
land that belonged to Islam at any point
in history belongs by right to Muslims
forever and that Muslims not only have a
responsibility to drive out the people
who drove them out but they have a
divine command to do so it is not
something that is optional it is not a
political view it is not the view of one
party as opposed to another it is a
command no less important for Muslims
than the Ten Commandments are for Jews
and Christians drive them out from where
they drove you out is the perfect word
of the creator of the universe and thus
it is a command from him that you have
to take with the utmost
seriousness now you can say say well the
the Israelis didn't actually drive the
Arabs out you're quite right uh the Arab
League and the Arab higher committee
ordered the Arabs to leave in
1948 because they thought that the Sunni
States surrounding Israel would
obliterate Israel and then the Arabs
could move back and meanwhile they'd be
out of the line of fire the fact is
though that that that reality although
it's abundantly documented has been
completely obscured in the Palestinian
rhetoric by the false claim that Israel
drove the Arabs out and the reason for
the false claim was to trigger the
relevance of the Divine
command that you establish that they
drove out the Israelis that the drove
Israelis drove out the Arabs
then the Arabs have a responsibility
before God to drive out the Israelis
there is no mitigation of that and every
negotiated settlement
has not been a rejection of that
although many of the Arabs took them to
be so Yasser Arafat after the conclusion
of the Oslo Accords in the '90s went
back home and he said in Arabic not in
English don't worry about this this is
like the Treaty of hudia what's the
Treaty of hudia it's a treaty that
Muhammad concluded when he was weak and
at a disadvantage and then he broke it
when he was stronger and had an
advantage but the larger point is that
the negotiations Arafat saw the
negotiations and he was explaining to
his people that the negotiations were
only a means to an end and that end was
to destroy Israel
altogether now the trigger of this
immediate conflict was that the Israelis
were caught napping and we don't know
the full story of that yet but we know
that they had a very light presence if
any at the Gaza border and
the they bulldozed the Gaza the the
fence at the Gaza border and were able
to stream across and of course paraglide
it into the music festival you all know
the stories now why did that all that
happen because Hamas had convinced the
Israelis that they were more interested
in governing Gaza than in fighting
Israel and they and Ali Baraka who's a
top Hamas official went on Russia tele
Russian television RT the day after the
attacks October 8th and explained all
this and boasted about how they fooled
the Israelis and he said that we made
them think that we were not a threat now
why do the Israelis believe this because
nobody is thinking about this as a
religious war and yet that's what it is
and the religion tells them Muhammad
said you can lie in several
circumstances you should never lie but
if you're a husband and you need to lie
to your wife to keep things quiet go
ahead and if you're in war lie war is
deceit
now why don't the Israelis keep that
uppermost in their mind when they're
dealing with what Hamas is telling them
because nobody nobody in this conflict
except me and maybe a few other people
are saying Islam has to do with this war
this war has everything to do with Islam
this war cannot be understood properly
without Islam as the great Daniel
Greenfield said it's is it's about Islam
stupid and he was he was absolutely
right this is not a war that can be
properly analyzed or any solution found
without taking Islam into account if the
Israelis had never considered the
possibility of believing what Hamas was
telling them and even what Hamas was
doing and showing them but always kept
in mind drive them out from where they
drove you out that's the Hamas objective
they would never have let their guard
down one and so we also have to remember
this is already a World
War it is already World War I now what
do I mean by that Mahmud aahar another
homas official he said this is not just
a conflict with Gaza see people think if
they get their Palestinian State then
it'll be okay or if they destroy Israel
even it'll be okay no mmud aahar said
this is a conflict with any system of
unbelief and we're going to destroy
Christianity we're going to destroy the
other religions and Islam will reign
supreme
now is he going to is Islam going to
rule the world I don't think so but are
they going to kill a lot of people
trying absolutely is anybody paying
attention to that no that is not a
question that anybody is willing to
consider because it would be
islamophobic to do so and so this is the
truth of this conflict if even if God
forbid Israel were destroyed in this
conflict which I don't think it will be
but even if in the worst case scenario
that were to happen there would still
not be peace in the Middle East instead
you'd have emboldened jihadis moving
against Europe and against the United
States and so uh well that is the
situation as it stands and these
gentlemen will elucidate more of
[Applause]
it what happened that's something that
the great Robert Spencer raised and it's
something you don't see in the media you
can watch MSNBC CNN Fox News they'll
give you non-stop 24/7 coverage of the
latest Hamas propaganda that 7 billion
Palestinian children were killed on the
last two minutes by Israeli bombs
courtesy of the statistics from the Gaza
Ministry of Health and Rocket storage
and of course there'll be lots of
videos there'll be lots of videos of air
strikes but they're not going to answer
the basic question of Journalism what
happened in the lead and that's
something uh Robert Spencer touched on
what happened in the days and the weeks
before the attacks what isn't the media
discussing well let me tell you
something you will not hear in the media
10 days before the attacks Israel and
Kamas agreed to a
ceasefire did you hear thatone in the
media raise your hands no funny when
there all the people are screaming the
proas protest are screaming in the
streets ceasefire ceasefire ceasefire
there was a ceasefire in place when
Kamas attacked it was under a
ceasefire yeah it was under a ceasefire
that that's why they want another
ceasefire um Robert Spencer again
mentioned the Treaty of hubad so there
was a ceasefire in place it been
negotiated 10 days before the attacks
themselves
began and as part of the ceasefire uh
Hamas got a bigger fishing Zone more
visas for people from Gaza to enter
Israel and Israel got an got a cessation
of the violence there had been border
riots explosives have been thrown at
Israeli soldiers um incendiary balloons
were being used to set fire to the
fields and some of of the same
communities that were attacked and after
the ceasefire negotiated by Way by
cutter the Islamic Terror state of cter
which is a state sponsor of Hamas which
is now currently engaged in negotiating
to release the terrorists you can trust
them of
course Hamas pulled back the AR at the
borders Israelis went into the final
days of the high hly day season
believing that everything was okay there
was a light Force at the border most of
the focus was on the West Bank because
the violence there had been in the West
Bank and Gaza had been fairly peaceful
for about 2 years as far as Hamas went
um Hamas built up credibility uh to give
everybody the impression that it could
be trusted to follow its commitments of
course Kamas leaders also said that
they' been planning the attack for two
years for those two years there was a
certain amount of quiet because those
were the two years that Kamas was
planning the attack now here's a bit of
a funny thing National Security adviser
Jake suvan had an article in foreign
affairs magazine Des describing his
great diploma achievements among them
was de escalating Gaza using the pacy
between is and Kamas now the funny thing
about this article is if you find the
print version of the article you can
still find those words there but online
those words have been erased they no
longer appear in the article because
National Security adviser Jake suin is
no longer as eager to take credit for
his incredible diplomatic achievement
because his diplomatic achievement led
to the murder of over a th000
Israelis that's what diplomacy had
accomplished now the thing is cutter
didn't just play us this way this time
they played us the same way twice cutter
was the one under whose offices the
agreement with the Taliban was
negotiated in
Afghanistan and the Taliban agreed to
join a multi-party
government and the United States would
withdraw from Afghanistan and the moment
the United States began withdrawing from
Afghanistan the talian began conquering
Afghanistan Province by province and you
know what the state department did the
state department kept insisting until
the very last minute that the Taliban
were just building up leverage to form a
multi-party government the Taliban
conquered a third of Afghanistan half of
Afghanistan and the state department
kept negotiating with them to for form a
multi-party
government of course cutter had managed
to pull off the same thing twice within
a matter of a few years both the first
time leading to the Taliban conquest of
Afghanistan the second time leading to
the brutal Hamas attack and the swau the
worst Slaughter of Jews since the
Holocaust have we learned anything from
the experience absolutely not
that we learn anything from the time
that Q was hosting khik Muhammad The
Mastermind of September 11th we went in
there to try to get them the qari tipped
off khich Muhammad he was off on a
government plane before he could whistle
we were nothing from that experience
because right now we're still thanking
cutter for engaging in negotiations now
let's talk about the terms of the
ceasefire that Hamas wanted what did
Hamas want they wanted a bigger fishing
Zone what did they do with that fishing
Zone did they go fishing did they catch
some trout no they use that to Launch
Naval invasion of Israel now what about
the work visas in 2021 Secretary of
State Tony blinkin spoke at J Street the
anti-israel lobby group and he told J
Street that um one of the things that he
was had convinced the israelies to do to
make life better in Gaza was to provide
work visas to gazans to come and work in
Israel after Hamas took over Gaza Israel
logically closed it down because you
don't want people who want to kill you
into your country they only allowed
people in for medical care and even that
was too much
but in 2019 and in 2021 Israel
significantly expanded the Visa program
the um work permit program by 2019 um
they were allowing in some 12,000 by 20
by 2021 it was about 19,000 under Natan
Unfortunately they kept the program and
they expanded it over to about 21,000
now they're finding these work permits
over the place in Israel now on the
bodies of the Dead terrorists because
the terrorists knew exactly what who was
living in those communities what their
security Arrangements were people who
survived in those communities are saying
that the terrorists knew who lived where
how many kids they had even if they had
a dog all those day laborers they R into
their communities those day laborers
came back as terrorists they provided
Hamas with info on how to attack those
communities how to bypass them and how
to kill everybody in
there now did nobody see this attack
coming of course they saw the attack
coming we just dismissed it as
impossible inconceivable if you actually
go back to September um in September the
media is reporting that there are border
riots on the border and that Hamas is
practicing quote storming settlements
and kidnapping Israelis but all the
experts including our experts come out
and they say that Hamas does not
actually mean this they're just doing
this in order to improve their position
the negotiating position for the
negotiations just like up until about a
week before Cabell fell the state
department was insisting that um the
taban were just improving their position
for the negotiations so we actually saw
Hamas doing this in plain sight but
nobody took it seriously because we
believe that Hamas was a rational actor
that they were not out to do this again
as Robert Spencer said uh these are
really the roots of This Disaster um
because the moment you believe you can
trust terrorists the terrorists have set
you up for the kill and that is the
fundamental catastrophe here and
absolutely nobody none of the people
responsible for this particularly in the
state department want to claim credit
for this want to talk about how they
enable the terrorist to go into GA to go
into Israel from Gaza they don't want to
talk about their's diplomatic successes
but they're still doubling down on the
idea that there is a negotiated solution
that diplomacy can work with terrorists
and of course it can never work with
terrorists one minute okay the
fundamental catastrophe here is that we
continue being played the same way
whether it's by cter whether it's by
Iran whether it's by all the various
Islamic terrorists and their state
sponsors we believe that they want the
same things that we do Hamas was getting
in $2 million a day from those work
permits and so it was ass assumed that
Hamas would not do anything to interfere
with that but Hamas cares about more
than the 2 million in work permits or
the bigger fishing zone is killing
Israelis all the Hamas negotiations were
aimed at only one thing and one thing
alone and that was being able to invade
and Israel and kill as many Israelis as
possible what we saw was the expression
of what Hamas had been all along back in
the day Hamas was described as a social
work group back when it was operating
under the usual Muslim brothered rules
as it got more and more violent we still
keep talking kept talking about how it
wanted some sort of um negotiated
solution how it wanted to open up Gaza
um the B Administration pressured Israel
into opening up Gaza to make life better
for gazans this this is still the thing
that they're obsessed with get
humanitarian Aid into Gaza make life
better for gazans and they are going to
turn around it never works that way
because that is not what Hamas wants it
is not what any of the so-called
Palestinians want it is not what any of
the Islamic terrorist that we are up
against
want what they want is the absolute
destru C of civilization our
civilization it's as again as Robert
Spencer said it is their Divine and
there is their religious Mission we
still insist on thinking of the musim
mors operating by our paradigms they're
only operating by their Paradigm when we
negotiate with them we have two choices
we are either appeasing them and if we
are negotiating them then the bottom
line is we are appeasing them or we are
ready to actually fight them and Destroy
them there are a lot of lessons from
Israel for us our border is far more
open than Israel's was we are far more
prone to trusting terrorists and taking
them in and if something were to happen
on our border we would be far more at
risk than Israel was what would happen
if 100,000 armed men 250,000 armed men
showed up on our border and started
killing us in the same way are we ready
for it I don't believe that we are
there's a lot of things for us to learn
from the disaster from the atrocity from
the catastrophe that happened in Israel
and there are things for us to RN also
from Israel's response the Israelis now
have decided that they have no choice
but to destroy Kamas
we need to learn from that that we have
no choice but to destroy Islamic
terrorism we cannot negotiate it with it
we cannot coexist with it we cannot
treat it as a rational actor we must
either go to war and win or we must
surrender to it the Israelis are going
to war let us go to war as well and
destroy it once and for
Alles well the great Robert Spencer had
the pleasure of taking on Islam and the
great Daniel Greenfield had the pleasure
of taking on the US government I have
the less great pleasure of taking on the
Israeli
government
um I'm a historian and I just wrote a
book on this subject actually submitted
it uh at the end of September uh which I
called Israel Israel Victory and as I
see it the Israeli well let's call it
the Israeli Palestinian conflict though
it wasn't called that back in the old
days
the Israeli Palestinian conflict goes
back 140 years to 1880 and there are
three eras the first was the era of 1880
to 1948 until the state of Israel came
into being when the Jewish Community the
yeshu was weak but very smart so smart
that in 1948 it was able to defeat six
Arab State armies with very small
resources from 1948 to 1973 25 years the
Israeli took on the Arab states
Palestinians didn't matter at that point
Arab states Egypt Jordan Syria and it
did incredibly well it had good
resources and it used them to the utmost
and 1967 was arguably the greatest
military victory in human
history 1973 to the present the Arab
states have receded with only a couple
of minor exceptions the Arab states have
not been military engaged against Israel
instead the Palestinians have come back
and now Israel is is the party with the
great resources the
f-35s the high tech industry the startup
Nation Israel has all
the uh material power the Palestinians
have almost none and yet in this third
era the Israelis have gone from this
enormous cleverness Inc competence to
All Out
incompetence since 1967 in 1967 the
Israelis took over the West Bank in Gaza
the so-called Dian policy was put into
fact which said basically as long as you
gin and West Bankers don't attack us
physically we're okay with you you can
teach think preach whatever you like we
don't care just don't attack us well and
by the way we'll help you get
richer uh in
1993 shiman Perez and others at the Oslo
Accords built on that and said we're
going to give you everything you want a
state um functioning econ om just leave
us
alone and in 2005 Ariel Chiron took it a
step further and said we're going to
leave Gaza yeah we're taking some
uh casualties CU so we're going to leave
Gaza we're going to let you run it this
series of incompetencies 1967 93 and
2005 is the background to where we are
today the Israelis just didn't take it
seriously they thought because they're
now strong they don't need to pay much
attention to this clearly weak adversary
um a man I respect very much Ephraim in
inbar a strategist in Israel he
persistently called the Palestinians a
strategic
nuisance strategic nuisance uh they just
didn't take him seriously Perez said I
pay attention to what they do not what
they say or think so this Islamic and
nationalist fervor built and built and
the the Israelis just didn't pay
attention the key which has been alluded
to is the phrase something to lose the
the the Israeli policy was to hope that
the gazen administration of Hamas the
West Bank administration of the
Palestinian Authority would have
something to lose whether it be fishing
zones or employment in Israel or other
benefits and therefore they would get
tame uh they persuaded themselves of
this I've been arguing with them for
years the security establishment just
would not see this they had what they
call the concept and the concept was
enrich them plate them and they will
eventually come around now the question
is what next
um clearly Hamas needs to be extrap
needs to be destroyed it's going to be
difficult um and clearly after that and
I might get dissent on the panel from
this this uh is not an Israeli
occupation of Gaza which no one wants
it's certainly not having the
Palestinian Authority which is almost as
bad as Hamas and much weaker than Hamas
take over in Gaza it's not having an
international contingent come in and
take over it's not having the Arab
states take over Egypt doesn't want to
take over I believe that there is
actually something positive that come
out of this uh tragedy and that is the
following since 20 8 since December 2008
for almost exactly 15 years the gazen
population has been used in a unique way
we're all familiar with the notion of
Canon fodder of of poor unprepared
soldiers being sent out for example in
bakut in Ukraine the Vagner prison
recruits were just thrown in and how
many died it didn't matter that's
historically quite common what Hamas did
was something unique as far as I know
know which was to use its population not
to win on the battlefield but to suffer
privation to suffer bombings to suffer
injury to suffer hunger to suffer death
and every time that happens hamas's
statue Rises the people are out on the
streets and in the campuses and Hamas
gains money from its supporters and
in uh it it gets the approval of the
Iranian overlords in tan so the gazin
population 15 years has been subjected
to destruction and death for hamas's
purposes Hamas is not interested in its
population except to use that population
to further its goals of destroying
Israel and that population I believe in
the course of this 15 years has changed
not the West Bank population West Bank
population remains quite radical but the
West Bank population by large has pulled
back just wants to live its life and
therefore I think the Israelis have a
real opportunity now
presumingly they take Gaza and they
control Gaza to work with gazin to set
up a police force to set up an
Administration and run the place in a
decent sort of way not a great way I'm
not looking for democracy I'm not
looking for friendship to Israel but
just a decent way in the sense that
Egypt and Jordan both of which are ruled
by incompetent dictators uh are decent
places they're not sending over missiles
to Israel they're not sending over uh
murderers to Marauder uh but are living
quietly Side by sign with Israel I think
the Israelis have the chance to build up
a Cadre of gin with whom they can work
not a state nothing Grand but something
decent and then presumably they could do
the same on the West Bank eventually so
I think something good come out of this
but the Israelis are so incompetent and
what we've seen in the last what 20 days
they continue to be incomp they had no
plan they no plan to take over Gaza
that's why it's taking so long so let's
hope they get shocked into to competence
but I am not counting on
[Applause]
it well good morning everybody um Having
learned almost everything that I know
about this subject from the three people
on this panel I'm going to try to just
round out what they've already told you
with a couple of other thoughts about
what is going on here um I completely
agree though I think I would
characterize it a little bit differently
with Robert's suggestion that we're in a
religious War I would suggest we're in a
spiritual war this is good versus evil
and Western Civilization has its flaws
but by comparison with the
Alternatives it's pretty clear that
we're the good and the evil is
abounding what we're
seeing in the Middle East at the moment
I believe is a function not only of the
interests and evil of the
immediate actors about which we've heard
some this
morning Hamas
notably uh Hamas is
Isis as has been pointed out by among
others the
Israelis Hamas is also the Muslim
Brotherhood Hamas is also the Taliban
Hamas is also Hezbollah and so on the
these are in short all people who
Embrace yes a religious program but as
Robert has taught me uh it is first and
foremost a political
program uh and I'm speaking specifically
of
sharia the doctrine that uh impels among
other things Jihad
and there's really not a dimes worth of
difference between the various adherence
to Sharia
and
the program that they follow because it
is all governed by that Doctrine and
what does that mean that means it is
their
obligation to use violence wherever
possible to achieve the Triumph of
Islam worldwide
and that is a big problem because there
are a lot of people not all Muslims let
me hasten to add but an awful lot of
them who do believe that that is their
obligation as faithful Muslims and that
is certainly the view of the authorities
of
Islam so if that were not bad enough of
course we have the problem that we
remain
utterly
confused about all of
that the president of the United
States
yesterday met with three representatives
of the Muslim
Brotherhood no they're not billing
themselves as such one is the Attorney
General of
Minnesota Keith
Ellison another is a guy who runs M Gage
which is political action operation with
whom Biden met before he was
elected and plated in exchange for their
support and contributions that he would
populate his administration with
Muslims meaning they Muslims the Muslim
Brotherhood and then third a personal
favorite of mine uh was Imam Muhammad
maid that may not be a household name
but if you're following these guys he is
the past president of the largest Muslim
Brotherhood front in the United States
the Islamic Society of North America he
is also one of their top influence
operators he serves on the US
International religious freedom
commission as a presidential
appointee he runs a nine I think it's
nine maybe it's more now mosque complex
in Northern
Virginia all of them
Jihadi now it's stealth Jihad here
mostly I term I think Robert
coin but it's indistinguishable in terms
of its agenda from that that is being
pursued
elsewhere I did want to introduce just
one other piece of this though um in
addition to Iran which has been of
course the great enabler of all of this
with its money with its
missiles with
its US government supplied
funding enabling
the Jihad that we've just witnessed and
more generally that we are experiencing
and will
worldwide but there's one other element
in this and I'm going to shamelessly the
company of all these authors hold up the
book my new one which is
outside is about the guys who I believe
Have Been instrumental in all of this
and who are bringing us the Third World
War
and who are poised to win
it the way things are going and that
would be the Chinese Communist
party and communist China has clearly
greenlighted the invasion of Ukraine
they've greenlighted the invasion of
Israel and my guess is they've got a
couple more places that they intend
to light matches and set off Tinder
boxes
before we get to their
Invasion which is
coming and that would be of course
involving Taiwan but I don't think it'll
be confined to Taiwan because it's very
clear that they regard
us as the obstacle to the realization of
their totalitarian Ambitions which is to
rule the world and it will be a very
interesting thing to
see how these guys Square
Off
the guys who believe that Allah has
destined them to be the world
hamon and the Chinese Communist Party
who believes xingping has destined them
to
become that
hamon the point is it's not going to be
good for us and I'll just leave you with
this closing cheerful
thought this world war
unlike the previous
two will have a home front feature to
it that is
coming and in part it has been greatly
exacerbated
by President Biden who decided to allow
the borders to be completely decimated
so that any number of what it appears
are predominantly
unaccompanied military aged
fit young
men some of whom are from every garden
spot in the Muslim
world and that's not even counting the
70 to 100,000 that Biden imported from
Afghanistan after we surrendered the
place to
them but there are by some estimate
several divisions worth of Chinese
people's Liberation Army my special
operators who have also benefited from
the open border and are now with your
tax dollars disseminated all over the
United
States so we are in a world
war there will be more of these
congrations I anticipate maybe Korea
maybe Pakistan and India maybe Latin
America who knows but there will also be
a war here and we best be getting ready
for it and we are not at the moment
thank
you thank all you gentlemen uh okay you
sir um you
all have a unified voice in that you're
saying there is not a conspiracy
anymore it is obvious you all agree with
that am I on the mark do you mean a
conspiracy on our
part of course not well I I know that
what we're saying here would have been
dismissed up until recently and still is
in many circles as a conspiracy theory
but it's obvious just reality it's just
reality okay now there's a lot of
collusion is the way I would put it
whether they've conspired or not okay
now having said that we also know that
our federal government in part or in ho
is in on that pollution that's that's
obvious to anyone who looks at it
objectively now what you I didn't get
from you was a
prescription on how to turn the bus
around because once the bus is going
forward it has a lot of energy thank you
but if you can divert that energy if you
can push on it it will crash and burn so
how how can we start the push against
baring bus to get it to go off the road
and and destroy itself because with all
these factions that you're talking about
the Chinese the the islamist world um
with their
own individual very very um
personal worldviews and and and and
fighting in between them um which is
pretty common too um what can we do
please be prescripted thank
you i' take i' take a cut at it if I can
um I I'm all about prescriptions so
thank you for asking the question so
pointedly um let me let me just take a
piece of this because they're lots of it
and we've got much more experts people
on the Middle East especially than me um
in the book we've got 20 specific
recommendations as to what we do about
the Chinese Communist Party the single
most important one of which is to
address directly what I think is the
single most important facet of what they
call unrestricted Warfare that they've
been waging against us which
is Elite
capture Joe Biden is the poster child of
elite
capture he has populated his
administration with people like him who
have also I believe been working with
and for the Chinese Communist party we
have members of Congress similarly we
have Financial uh Masters of the
Universe and other Business Leaders we
have media personalities and owners we
have academic
Galore and Hollywood all more or less
batting as Joe Biden likes to say for
the other team
we've got to fix
that especially if as I fear is the case
we are now moving from this pre cantic
unrestricted Warfare into a shooting War
kind and it is simply well not only
intolerable but
suicidal to have people who are working
for the Chinese Communist Party having
anything to do with the
power in this country political economic
Financial what have you so I invite you
to take a look for other prescriptions
but that gives you the the the hardest
nut frankly because this is a very well
established and fatal problem I see the
problem a bit differently more
profoundly uh we are a
rich country at peace we are
powerful and we are Blas we do not feel
there are real
dangers uh
no
power since World War II has been as
strong as we are and therefore we
feel
easy U
guilty uh we make no real efforts I made
that point about the Israelis a few
minutes ago and I think it applies as
much or more to us we just don't take
this seriously and look at 9/11 all of
us live through that and the shock of
that and United We stand and the
national unity and sentiments and how
long did that last a year maybe two and
then we went back because we're just so
strong so big so happy so content and I
fear it'll take enormous disaster to
wake Americans up uh and it's not
happening and I don't see it in Israel
and I don't see it here we and I don't
see it in Europe and I don't see in
Japan I don't see it in the wealthy
democracies we just don't worry and now
we're confronted with China uh and we're
just not
worried Daniel Rob care to respond well
we can also um Frank mentioned uh
Chinese uh figures in the government um
there also uh Daniel pipes was recently
discussing mamus ones there are two
Pentagon Chiefs of Staff that we've
exposed thus far who have ties to the
government of Iran and cter and one of
those uh people right now also is ties
to the Muslim brother
and is advocating for Hamas on her
Instagram account uh the B
Administration is Bard some of the worst
actors possible it is really vital to
clean uh these people out of the
government and to actually go back to
what we're doing um early on after
September 11th which is to tackle the
Muslim Brotherhood presence in America
the Muslim Brotherhood presence uh no as
um D pipes correctly mentioned Muslim
Brotherhood Hamas is an arm of the
Muslim Brotherhood we've got Hamas in
America we have to clean these people
out to go back to the original roots of
the Muslim brother organizations they
built up a vast political infrastructure
much of which is now networked with the
Democratic party uh for example when the
Southern Poverty Law Center was putting
in $100 million to change um elections
to change the political makeup in places
like Georgia um the islamist groups were
on that they benefited from that
massively about 10% of the democratic
delegation in Georgia now is Muslim
which is wildly unprecedented they're
less than 1% of the population so the
Muslim brother is well on its way of
gaining political power in the United
States we should not underestimate them
there are thousands of ilhan Omars now
running for political office on the
Statewide level uh this is a crisis we
need to urgently address and we need to
urgently address the problem of islamist
infiltrators across the federal
government including at top levels of
the
Pentagon one small note of encouragement
is that this Grand Coalition of evil is
already showing signs of strain uh we
see that the left in pushing its insane
cultural agenda and I can tell you that
speaking as an Asian woman myself
the the fact is that it's Muslim groups
in the United States who have been among
the strongest in opposing the imposition
of this insanity and this sexual
depravity and everything else the trans
Madness and all that on primary school
children and such it's been Muslims
who've been standing against that now
this has gotten a lot of people on the
right very excited and I would caution
against that because they think oh now
we can be friends and it's so pathetic
you know and I understand being isolated
for so many years people want to have uh
their own coalitions and they think that
the Muslims that are protesting against
this madness will be reliable allies
that they have not stopped they've not
dropped any of their Islamic principles
which Hold Us in contempt and demand our
subjugation and we should remember that
but the fact that there is large scale
and growing rejection in the Muslim
communities in the west of the lgbtq
business is a is a welcome sign that
could collapse the whole left into
infighting and divert them from their
larger
goals thank you gentlemen and I'm sorry
I misgender misgendered you earlier
Robert I'll be filing soon pronoun
police I believe I believe Phyllis has a
question next I I absolutely love that
Robert that was a classic and actually
the question I was originally going to
ask was you sort of went over it when
you made your answer so my fallback
question would be um in terms of Israel
and going in and saying they're going to
smash amas great they'll do it but I
think we all know and they must know
that a new I iteration is going to take
their place and I'm wondering what
future plans they
have uh for whether it be 5 years or
however many years because we all know
that there that these people are not
like the US they will take their time
and so um I'm just wondering what you
think about what will happen Happ after
Hamas is gone and some new organization
or some new group with a new name is
going to come in and do the exact same
thing well I'm advocating an
Administration in Gaza that will be
comparable to those in Egypt and Jordan
and they're tough and they crack down in
other words not all Muslims are members
of the Muslim Brotherhood or islamist
there plenty who are on the other side
including the leaders of Jordan and
Egypt so I would like to see them do
something comparable and they would so
it's up to the Israelis to find the
right gazin to be the tough guys in Gaza
who keep out the Hamas like the islamist
organizations it it isn't that difficult
they it isn't that difficult plenty of
other rulers in the Middle East are
doing that all the time look at
Tunisia you know they do it they do it
well they know how to suppress their
islamists you're absolutely right that
one Hamas is gone they'll just be a new
Jihad group there were already new Jihad
groups that are more popular than Hamas
and Gaza including the Lions of Allah
who are much more violent than Hamas so
it's only a temporary solution it's
buying a little time to destroy Hamas
and then these other groups will build
up unless as Daniel is saying then the
whole principle is directly fought
against but what also needs to be done
is ultimately the Arab states in the
neighborhood have to relent and Grant
the Palestinian Arab citizenship which
they have denied because they want to
exacerbate this problem and prolong it
and if they did that then a lot of them
would leave they they they don't want to
be in this situation anymore than
anybody else I'm not saying that none of
them do and they're all moderates I just
mean a lot of people would really rather
not be waging Jihad all the time and
they would go they would take the
opportunity to go live in Jordan or
Syria and have a normal life or Scotland
Scotland yes Hamza YF is the first no no
no no Hamza YF is the first minister of
Scotland a man of Pakistani Origins and
he has invited the Gins to come to
Scotland so can you imagine Israel has
two basic
next no no go ahead go ahead what do you
think was the president's OB no sorry
sorry we've got the mic over there but
this gentleman this gentleman
next all right thank y'all you you for
been leading the way in trying to
educate people on the dangers of radical
Islam um I do have to stand a bit in
defense of all leaders in the Middle
East being
incompetent uh put yourself in
netanyahu's place I mean he even when he
had a republic Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo Pompeo is negotiating with the
Taliban he's the guy that negotiated
that terrible deal the withdrawal
netanyahu's got the Liberals in Israel
he's having to try to Plate them with
his hands tied uh in in Egypt Ali is not
really that diplomatically Eep but uh he
understands what's going on he doesn't
like the mus Muslim Brotherhood there
are leaders around the Middle East that
would like to do more but with the
crazies in
America been the most powerful country
they're putting we are putting so much
pressure on the people who are competent
in the Middle East that they're having
to make poor decisions because of our
pressure it's our doing I'm encouraged
this week with Mike Johnson becoming
speaker but otherwise
you
know it's it's not been a body that's
been terribly helpful in standing up
against radical Islam so I applaud
y'all's years of standing up for the
right things but there are competent
leaders in the Middle East I I'd just
like a comment uh on the broad brush
there well uh on September 20th um Biden
finally agreed to meet with prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu after
putting him off for as long as possible
and one of the things that Biden told
Netanyahu was that he had to deescalate
in Gaza if the normalization talks with
um Saudi Arabia were to go forward so
part of what happened with the Kamas
attack was also the pressure from the
Biden Administration to deescalate in
Gaza which meant bribing Kamas this is a
pattern that began under the Obama
Administration uh every time Hamas
attacked Israel would respond and then
maybe for two or 4 days they abominated
Administration would affirm as's right
to defend itself then right afterward
they would insist on a ceasefire and to
get a ceasefire from Kamas you obviously
have to do something for Hamas so this
is unfortunately a pattern of the United
States particularly the Obama and B
administrations pressuring Israel it is
no coincidence that the worst
catastrophic terrorism has happened
under Obama and then now under Biden
ever since Biden began pouring money
again back into the West Bank in Gaza
terrorist attacks increase dramatically
and this is something that Israel has
nool control if we fund terrorism if the
United States government if the White
House the B Administration funds
terrorism Israel can only do so much
about that oh good we get to have an
argument it's very kind of the two of
you to defend the Israeli leadership and
blame it all on Washington on Obama and
Biden I'm not defending Obama and Biden
but for example 1993 the oso Accords was
not imposed by the United States in fact
the first American reaction uh by the
Clinton Administration was very cool we
didn't like this all that much 2005 when
the Israelis withdrew from Gaza this was
not under American pressure it came as a
complete surprise to the Americans the
Israelis make their own mistakes don't
blame Americans for Israeli mistakes
please could I just
say Lou
Gomer thank you to you and Michelle
Bachman and Trent Franks and a few
others
for getting this Muslim Brotherhood
peace and for challenging the United
States government under Republican and
Democratic administrations by the way uh
for aligning with it or uh allowing it
to be influential in our circles
alas none of the three of you are in
Congress any longer and um I'm I'm
hopeful that Mike Johnson who
interestingly enough get this
folks as a state
legislator in
Louisiana took the lead on getting the
House of Representatives in that state
legislature to adopt a
resolution calling upon law enforcement
in the state not to engage in Outreach
with the Council on American Islamic
relations so there may be hope yet we'll
look for your influence here thank you
I'd like to come out against both the
American and Israeli governments uh
I think it's clear that the Israeli
government suffered a massive failure of
intelligence and it should fall and
there should be a stronger government in
its place we'll see how that sorts out
but in the meantime let's not forget
that Joe Biden went over to meet with
Netanyahu and what did he do he gave
$100 million to Hamas and make no
mistake that is $100 million to Hamas he
gave $100 million to Gaza for
humanitarian Aid and he said you know if
Hamas gets this it will just show
they're bad well we already knew they
were bad and there's nothing in Gaza to
prevent Hamas from getting that that
money there's no entity to which the US
government can give that $100 million
and it will not end up with Hamas and
even if it is all peanut butter for
sandwiches there will be some way it can
be used in Rockets they got water piping
to to for for for irrigation and used it
for Rockets these people they stop at
nothing so you give a $100 million to
Gaza you're funding Hamas right okay I'm
afid afid this is going to have to be
the last question on a little different
subject what was the president's
objective when he immediately opened the
Border when he got in
office destroy the United
States which is by the way I will tell
you I I tried to study this pretty
closely I think I'm not exaggerating in
saying that every policy
he's adopted has had two things in
common both domestic and
foreign they're bad for
America and they're good for the Chinese
Communist party and or other enemies of
our
country I I would slightly amend Frank's
answer to the question why did Biden
open the border and I would say it's to
find new voters new Democratic voters to
destroy the United
States